what's happening with your tax money
President Trump said I'm going to cut
some Dept we are proposing a budget that
will shrink the bloated federal
bureaucracy but that didn't happen
quietly Congress increased spending and
the very department's Trump wanted to
cut important-sounding agencies like the
Agriculture Department which raises the
question what's the Agriculture
Department oh um should he do a bunch of
things no one I asked knew what does
agriculture do FDA no 3/4 of the money
goes for programs like food stamps and
lots of that is wasted billions went to
dead people and billions more go for
corporate welfare farm subsidies years
ago politician said government must help
farmers to make sure America has an
ample food supply the whole thing is a
big boondoggle which gives some farmers
subsidies but the vast majority of
farmers don't get subsidized and it
still gets grown yes somehow we always
have enough vegetables and fruit crops
that don't get subsidies the subsidies
mostly go to grain and corn farmers the
richest farmers get most of the handouts
what they're really doing is taking from
the private sector and they're giving it
to special interests and yet at the same
time the government demands other
farmers grow less to prop up cherry
prices the department told this farmer
destroy your crop he had to dump 40,000
pounds of perfectly good cherries on the
ground and let them rot the result is we
have fewer cherries and we have to pay
more for existing cherries that's not
helping other cabinet departments are
just as wasteful what about the Commerce
Department what do they do I have no
idea no one did
the department's biggest spending item
is supporting the global warming Science
Complex the ice is all so thin at an
alarming rate the Commerce Department
spends your money at an alarming rate
they brought a three hundred thousand
dollar yacht which the bureaucrats use
to go fishing the department also gives
money to
companies that have tech problems they
claim every dollar generates 30 they
take a dollar and then they get thirty
dollars of benefits for society all we
need to do is take more of your dog and
we get 30 times the amount the unseen is
if we're not spending that dollar that's
being taken from the economy too so if
we spend that dollar why doesn't that
become 30 dollars it is the biggest
Ponzi scheme example logic I've ever
heard of and think about just this idea
of a commerce department when one of the
founders was asked about creating the
department he said for heaven's sake
what's meant by a government Chamber of
Commerce commerce just happened we don't
need a commerce department don't you bet
thank you very
why don't we just let people do what
they wanted to interact freely wouldn't
that be nice but that's not what's
happening under Democrats and
Republicans government grows
you